-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and now, we're going
to get to the news.
In an interview
with CNN last night,
White House Press Secretary
Karine Jean-Pierre was asked
if President Biden's age
or stamina
will be a challenge
in his reelection bid.
Said Jean-Pierre, "No,
everything else will."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden criticized
large corporations
for keeping prices high
to boost profits,
in a speech last week, and said,
"Exxon made more money than God
last year."
Worse, they made it by selling
a natural resource,
so that's technically
God's money.
[ Laughter ]
During her opening statement
at yesterday's hearing
on the Capitol attack,
Republican Representative
Liz Cheney said that
an "apparently inebriated
Rudy Giuliani
told former President Trump
to falsely claim he won
on election night."
To be fair, his legal advice
doesn't get any better
when he's sober.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Are you drunk again?"
[ As Giuliani ]
Trust me, it's just as bad.
[ Laughter ]
During yesterday's congressional
hearing, it was revealed
that Donald Trump Jr.'s fiancée,
Kimberly Guilfoyle,
was paid $60,000 to speak at the
rally before the Capitol attack.
Well, technically,
$20,000 to speak
and then $40,000 to please stop.
[ Laughter ]
When asked if he will support
the bipartisan
gun legislation framework,
Republican Senator Mike Braun
said he was open to it,
but added he was,
"interested to see
where the NRA is on it,"
which is a little like saying
you're open to eating healthier,
but are interested to see
how Oreos feel about it, first.
[ Laughter ]
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
over the weekend appeared
on an episode of
"RuPaul's Drag Race All Stars."
Either that, or she didn't,
and that person should win.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean --
[ Cheering and applause ]
Mick Jagger announced yesterday
he tested positive
for the coronavirus
and Keith Richards announced
that's the only thing
he's tested negative for.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Beyoncé recently deleted
her profile pictures
on all social media platforms.
I just hope I can remember
what Beyoncé looks like.
[ Subdued laughter ]
Former President Trump
turned 76 today,
so now, he's really asking
everyone to stop the count.
[ Laughter and groans ]
That's right, today was
former President Donald Trump's
76th birthday.
Pretty impressive --
76, and he can still get
an insurrection.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
That man was our president!
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, rapper Snoop Dogg
recently tweeted
that the full-time blunt roller
he hired
now makes up to $50,000 a year,
which has to be the smallest
salary she's ever made.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
I bet they're
beautifully rolled.
[ Laughter ]
I bet they're beautifully,
artisanally rolled.
That was a monologue, everybody.